[Musique]
le chemin de la vendée verte dans les
pyrénées nous sommes fils de paysan et
nous parle en béarn est ce que c'est une
langue
du pays et noir à conserver et à la
montagne alors que sous fait cette année
on a fait un valet le matin se lever
très liés il a envoyé les brebis après
vers 11h le ch rire ferme et recommencez
pas encore toi tu as été non une fois
pour aller chercher une brebis
elle s'était perdue et mannequin à peine
jean paul ier après valence par là
revenir l'ail et au fromage
il arrive à deux par jour on en fait on
arrive à en arriver à un fai cadre
graphique venus vers la faible 1 faible
2 combien vous allez à vos billets à peu
près deux cents 200 l'été avec celle de
garde à vue mais là il reste un mois 5,8
à la montagne après un 1er juillet il
monte à la montagne l'arrière comme à la
saq kilembé terrestre
je comprends mieux saint-amand pas là
les portes ravitaillement je voudrais y
rester pour apprendre à faire le fromage
et mailhac au lit je peux pas tu sais
toi faire la fromagerie
d'abord il faut du les contrats liant
après
chaudron mais le lait ont fait chauffer
le lait caillé de précieux minogue
ouverture de sur le laisse reposer une
heure et après on le faire chauffer qui
bouge jusqu'à 40 degrés parce qu'on l'a
supposé de ce plan laisse reposer 10
minutes on a pris feu ramasser les
méduses moule après et par dessous en le
pico avait d éveiller et le petit lait
coule un ruisseau sera présenté au qatar
après ça soit relevée au saloir et après
il faut le salé le jour oui enfin on le
salue le matin qui apprend le laisse
poser jusqu'à qu'ils soient mûrs pour
revendre est que tu vas faire ton plus
tard manger faire paysanne berger ta
vieille montagne
pourquoi juste quoi avec les brumes et
les vents juste serait mieux serait plus
heureux peut-être doit trouver quelque
chose si je peux y est l'hiver tu vas y
avait backhaus l'hiver je hors des
vaches des limousines vais laisser
peuvent
le printemps je les ai envoyées à la
montagne en salle et et je prendrai des
brebis en garde
pourquoi tu as envie de faire plaisir
je n'aime pas la ville centre ou à
l'essence et polluent et la place et
fait trop de bruit aussi
[Musique]
salez
mon avis les marches qui n'avait pas de
lait il fallait les faire aller dans une
autre montagne ça fait là bas alors on
passe une colline à ça s'appelle le
centre de la capitale notamment bruit et
se dit voyons alors les marcheurs
regarder cette vers en mêlée s'est levée
samedi sa sympathie à la famille noble
alors la marée vous l'a dit ron
bussonnière garde à vue un petit tour
alors elle me dit comme ça j'aurais bien
vite voir un petit tour j'y vais je veux
voir cet ours
il était très jolie il avait été de 0,1
attention alors un bon jeu passait
derrière la baie sont les romains
étaient toujours en train de le voir car
et audincourt erreurs tous les yeux au
dessus et voilà mes ressources comme
fire ou godard mais j'attends la une
alors elle est en train de vouloir
défendre le petit nom après on est parti
à jamais
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bensaïd lavine pensez vous dans l'avenir
de la vallée la malice et continue comme
ça ça continue à ce rythme la vallée va
mourir tout cas tu donc tout se perd
mais les terres sont remplies grosse
comment il faut refaire revivre ça comme
un idiot c'est tout perdu à cause de
tout ce ballet gran je l'aimais zone
tout cela et nous y apportons portant
paysans et a presque pas le pedn ya là
que 3 ou 4 21 euros mais il en faudrait
plus on a vanté ya vers larié christian
svensson y avait un mort et christian
qui s'y sont mis il trésorier qu'elle
n'aime pas chez nous ils font péter
voulait aussi que c'est un mariage a vu
que la vallée voulait se paieront alors
elle a voulu faire un paysage avec ses
camarades tournant il faudrait que la
vallée revivre parce que c'est dommage
une vallée comme ça elle est jolie et
laisser une fois le drh et je ne
supportais chez les jeunes partent à la
vie parce que c'est un pan des verreries
de serre la main et je voudrais avoir
des machines mais c'est un vol d'un peu
partout dans la ville aux poumons que ce
mal tout ce que c'est mal se marier ici
et j'ai un vélo qui coule monnaie
la chaîne n'a pas cessé d'offrir un
bordelais s'ils en ont un peu plus paix
au monde les avaler quand il veut le
deschaux fédou voudrait faire tu as la
machine eux mêmes peuvent pas il faut
faire aussi un moustique et la fusillade
finale et ako la faucheuse et le râteau
valeurs que le reste influent même donc
appelé centre pour le faire parce que
c'est les jeunes je passe mais pas m
distance et le caviar puissent pénétrer
les jeunes ont peur d'aller se tordre
les chevilles en année pantin a été au
sol étaient toutes les voitures sur
matricule être un troisième paradis se
promènent voir ça que j'ai reçues autour
des maisons et c'est vraiment un
désastre à savoir ce qu'il ya eu prat et
il faut savoir viendrai vingt dix ans
d'ici ce sera un prêt de rôle ce sera
assez de bois à qui la fao temps à qui
la faute
lamazou au type qui va la musique c'est
la photo qui sera quelque chose qui
compte cependant connaissant rien que
les suu kyi comme les sauces les 110 ans
content d'avoir les sûr que je veux en
faire une foie gras est rien et par qui
et pour quoi vous parlez à bernay
parce qu'il faut savoir le câble et
parce que pour affoler vaches et les
brebis mais bon wagon camp d'en face est
ici toi vont rien comprendre là il faut
garder cette langue parce que depuis
tout petit notre nous faire une parade
le par les querelles a qui disent que
les parisiens me disais que c'était la
langue pour aller pour appeler les
vaches et les bonus c'est pas vrai c'est
pour parler entre nous c'est comme une
autre langue
elle est aussi belle que l'espagnol et
l'anglais cake est pratiqué dans la
vallée on l'a fait partir de la vallée
peut-être ne faut les voir revenir à
l'école apparemment c'est pour ça que
l'on conserve
[Musique]